[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Toni ja
kennst du eigentlich die Filme die
nackte Kanone gab es drei Teile also
schon mal davon gehört aber ich habe sie
nie gesehen okay also ich habe es
gesehen als ich noch ein kleiner
Teenager war
und fand das damals auch wirklich muss
schon sagen doch ziemlich witzig
natürlich manche Filme die altern sehr
schlecht und gerade Komödien manche
Komödien nach 30 Jahren oder so dann
sieht man das vielleicht mit dem anderen
Auge aber das Besondere an diesem Filmen
ist das da einer der Schauspieler nicht
nur irgendein Schauspieler war der in
diesem Film mitgespielt hat sondern der
war ein Mann der zu dieser Zeit wirklich
eine ja fast schon Legenden Status hatte
er war football star er war Verdi Ikone
er war everybody Starling und
mutmaßlicher Mörder seiner Ex-Ehefrau
dieses Verbrechen überschattet einfach
alles wegen seiner Brutalität wegen der
wahnsinnigen Aufmerksamkeit die es hat
und auch immer noch bekommt und
natürlich wegen des spektakulären
Prozesses und über genau diese Dinge
wollen wir in dieser und der nächsten
Folge sprechen bestimmt wisst ihr alle
zumindest grob worum es geht wenn ich
euch sage dass ich die nächsten drei
folgen um o.j Simpson drehen aber Mirko
fast doch den Fall einmal ganz kurz für
uns zusammen wir brauchen glaube ich
keine Angst zu haben dass wir hier jetzt
Spoilern da die Eckdaten glaube ich
sowieso bekannt sind
kurz nach Mitternacht in der Nacht vom
12 zum 13 juli 1994 finden Spaziergänger
in brandwood einem wohlhabenden
Stadtteil von Los Angeles die Leichen
von Nicole Brown und Ronald Goldman im
Eingangsbereich von Nicole Browns
Anwesen
beide sind durch mehrere Messerstiche
getötet worden als Haupt Tatverdächtiger
wird bald Nicoles Ex-Mann OJ Simpson
ausgemacht in einem 15 Monate
andauernden Strafprozess bei dem die
ganze Welt auf der Zuschauerbank sitzt
wird Simpson vom Vorwurf des Mordes
freigesprochen zwei Jahre später folgt
ein schulspruch in einem Zivilprozess
indem es nicht um eine Haftstrafe
sondern um finanziellen Schadensersatz
für die Angehörigen geht
Schadensersatz
wenn man darüber nachdenken komisches
Wort also als ob der Tod eines geliebten
Menschen einfach nur ein Schaden wäre
da befindet ein Gericht ein Mann des
Mordes für schuldig und kann ihn nicht
ins Gefängnis schicken sondern nur dazu
verdonnern ein paar Millionen an die
Hinterbliebenen zu zahlen von denen er
dann aber nur gut eine halbe Million
wirklich zahlt weil ein Großteil seines
Vermögens in Immobilien steckt die nicht
gepfändet werden können aber zu den
Prozessen kommen wir im zweiten Teil
jetzt erzählen wir erstmal die
Vorgeschichte
am 19 Mai 1959 wird in Frankfurt am Main
ein Mädchen geboren ihre Eltern Judith
und Luis Brown geben ihr den Namen
Nicole die Mutter ist deutsche der Vater
Amerikaner zu der Zeit ist er als
Korrespondent der armee-zeitschrift
Stars and Stripes in Deutschland
stationiert die Familie zieht jedoch
bald in die Vereinigten Staaten Nicole
wächst gemeinsam mit ihren Schwestern in
Dana Kalifornien auf später besucht sie
die Dehner Hirs Highschool und sie ist
dort außerordentlich beliebt ja das kann
man so sagen
1976 wird sie an ihre Highschool zur
Homecoming Queen gewählt also Homecoming
ist eine von diesen amerikanischen
Highschool Traditionen ein Riesenfest zu
Beginn jeden Schuljahres zu Ehren
ehemaliger Schüler die für diesen Anlass
ja
also erklärt sich selbst ne da gibt es
dann meist ein Bankett ein Footballspiel
einen großen Ball und manchmal sogar
eine Parade durch die Stadt und einer
der Höhepunkte ist eben die Wahl zur
Homecoming Queen eine Mischung aus
Schönheit und Beliebtheitswettbewerb und
Nicole ist schön und beliebt sie wird
als offen und freundlich beschrieben mit
einem sehr anziehenden Wesen die
Homecoming Wahl ist ein Home Run für die
17-jährige nach Abschluss der Highschool
im Sommer 1977 arbeitet die 18-Jährige
als Kellnerin im Daisys einem trendigen
Nachtclub in Beverly Hills eines Tages
spricht ein Mann sie an flirtet mit ihr
und bittet
ab das war OJ Simpson sagt ein Kollege
zu ihr aber Nicole zuckt nur mit den
Schultern wer ist OJ Simpson fragt sie
ein football star ich mache mir nichts
aus football
wer ist OJ Simpson diese Frage hätten
schon damals 1977 viele Amerikaner
beantworten können ja er ist ein
Football-Star eine der größten aller
Zeiten ein Rekordspieler aber er ist
weit über das Stadion hinweg bekannt und
beliebt er tritt immer wieder in kleinen
Rollen in Filmen und Chance auf er macht
Fernsehwerbung vor allem für die
Autovermietung Herz er ist einfach
wahnsinnig bekannt und populär das geht
so weit dass ich sogar Rassisten für den
schwarzen Footballspieler begeistern
können und erst recht die die
irgendwelche die diffusen Vorurteile
oder Ängste gegenüber schwarzen haben
ohne sie sich wirklich einzugestehen
wenn man sich die herzspots aus der Zeit
anschaut dann sieht man dann neben dem
super freundlichen OJ Simpson immer
nette weiße Mittelstands Omas oder Opas
oder süße Mittelstands Kinder das wirkt
so ein bisschen wie hey schaut her der
hat zwar dunkle Haut aber eigentlich ist
er einer von uns
wir erzählen das weil Rassismus in
diesem Fall auch eine Rolle spielen wird
allerdings auf ziemlich überraschende
Art aber dazu später mehr
1977 ist OJ Simpson jedenfalls reich
berühmt und beliebt er ist gerade 30
Jahre alt und plant seine
football-karriere zu beenden denn er
will auf dem Höhepunkt abtreten als
Legende
aber o.j wirkt auch auf jeden der im
begegnet wie ein richtig richtig guter
Typ super sympathisch charmant sehr
großzügig witzig jemand der alle Herzen
im Sturm erobert
außer Nicoles naja zumindest nicht auf
Anhieb oder zumindest lässt sie es sich
nicht anmerken
oJ wird zurückkommen und es wieder
probieren bis sie schließlich in ein
Date einwilligt wir wissen nicht ob sie
beim ersten Mal wirklich nicht wollte
oder nur die
uninteressierte Mrs harte get spielte
denn sehr schnell er liegt sie dann doch
OJS Zauber und er ihrem den einst kann
man sagen ab diesem Zeitpunkt kreist das
Leben der beiden nur noch um einander
was jetzt vielleicht romantisch klingt
ist in Wirklichkeit eine Tragödie
von Anfang an kann man so sagen weißt du
Mirko eigentlich reden wir heute gar
nicht über einen Mord über eine Tat
vielmehr reden wir über Jahre lang
Missbrauch jahrelange Gewalt und
Unterdrückung eine toxische Beziehung
wie man heute sagen würde mit einem Mord
am Ende der aber im Nachhinein fast
unvermeidlich passieren musste
ja oder eben gerade deshalb hätte
vermieden werden können weil doch im
Nachhinein alles so deutlich darauf
hinweist darauf wo das alles hinführen
wird aber natürlich in der Rückschau
kann man es sich natürlich wunderbar
einfach machen und fragen warum hat das
niemand verhindert die ersten Anzeichen
gibt es eigentlich gleich nach ihrem
ersten Date
Nicole wohnt zu dieser Zeit mit einem
Freund zusammen also wirklich eine
platonische Beziehung nur gute Freunde
als Nicole spielt nachts nach Hause
kommt fällt ihr Mitbewohner auf dass der
Reißverschluss ihrer Hose abgerissen ist
Nicole Scherz darüber wie
leidenschaftliches zuging und das ist
einfach im Eifer des Gefechts passiert
sei und ja wer weiß vielleicht stimmt
das einfach denn Leidenschaft und große
beiderseitige sexuelle Anziehung ja die
gab es definitiv aber auch OJS andere
unbekannte und dunkle Seite kommt sehr
schnell zum Vorschein seine Eifersucht
sein Kontrollwahn sein Besitz denken und
seine Gewalt
er drängt Nicole praktisch sofort aus
der WG mit ihrem Freund auszuziehen er
schenkt ihr ein Apartment einfach weil
er es kann und weil er den Gedanken
nicht erträgt dass ein anderer Mann um
sie herum ist im September 1977 also
ungefähr zwei drei Monate nach dem oh
Jamie call das erste Mal gesehen hat
nimmt er sie mit zu einem seiner Spieler
es ist ein wunderschöner Tag ojes
Schwester ist dabei eine Schwester von
Nicole und Mike ein Kumpel von o.j mit
dem scheint sich Nicole offenbar gut zu
verstehen und er erklärt ihr die ganzen
Feinheiten des Spiels oder läuft auf das
Spielfeld raus und Zink hat Nicole auf
der Tribüne zu sie ist völlig erstaunt
und gerührt dass er sie überhaupt in
dieser großen Menge sehen kann und vor
allem dass er in diesem Moment an sie
denkt das Spiel läuft fantastisch für
Audi er läuft über 200 Jahre alt das
sind so um die 180 Meter und er zieht
zwei touch Downs ein Spieler auf dem
Höhepunkt seiner Fähigkeiten und das
obwohl er da schon 30 ist und seit über
einem Jahr davon redet dass er abbaut
dass er nicht mehr so gut ist wie früher
und dass er aufhören will
sein Kumpel Mike glaubt zu wissen was
ihn in diesem Spiel so beflügelt o.j ist
verliebt und er gibt alles für Nicole
diese Touchdowns waren für dich Nicole
er macht das für dich ja und Nicole ist
hin und weg also klar wer wäre das nicht
ich meine es ist ja auch so schön
kitschig romantisch ja bis alles kippt
vom Spielfeld aussieht o.j wie Nicole in
ihrer Freude Mike einen Kuss auf die
Wange gibt also wirklich ein
freundschaftlicher
glückskuss auf die Wange nichts
dramatisches aber abends nach dem Spiel
da rastet oje aus
er schreit und Nicole bricht total
zusammen und heult und dann eine Stunde
später gehen sie mit ihren Schwestern
und Freunden essen und feiern als sei
überhaupt gar nichts gewesen aber es
bleibt nicht lange nur bei verbaler
Gewalt wann genau auch körperliche
Gewalt dazu kommt ist nicht ganz klar
aber noch im ersten Jahr ihre Beziehung
1978 ist sie nach einem schlimmen
täglichen Angriff von ihm im Haus ihrer
Eltern wahrscheinlich ein erster von
vielen Versuchen sich ihm zu entziehen
und es kommt zu einer wirklich bizarren
Situation oJ tut es leid und
wahrscheinlich tut es ihm wirklich leid
aber da kommen wir später noch mal drauf
zurück jedenfalls will er sich
entschuldigen und alles wiedergutmachen
und sie natürlich auch nie mehr schlagen
und ab jetzt würde alles besser werden
und überhaupt und sowieso und hier
bitteschön ich habe einen Porsche für
dich ja er kauft ihr einen Porsche als
Entschuldigung für die blauen Flecken
lässt ihn zum Haus ihrer Eltern liefern
und dort wird es richtig seltsam ihre
Eltern wissen nämlich nichts von der
Beziehung nicole hat ihnen nichts davon
erzählt weil sie Angst vor deren
Reaktion vor allem der ihres Vaters hat
denn der ist ein ziemlicher Rassist
vielleicht nicht ganz hundert Prozent so
ein derbes Nazi Schwein wenn ich das
darf aber definitiv ein meine Tochter
gebe ich nur einem weißen Typ allerdings
bewundert er reiche und erfolgreiche
Menschen noch mehr als er schwarze
verachtet und der nagelneue Porsche vor
seiner Tür glättet seine Wut sehr sehr
schnell und auch Nicole kehrt bald zur
o.j zurück und wird noch viele Male zu
ihm zurückkehren obwohl da nicht nur die
Gewalt ist er der wegen eines
freundschaftlichen wangenkusses vor
Eifersucht durchdreht geht immer und
immer wieder fremd und entschuldigt sich
mit Worten Tränen leeren Versprechungen
und weiteren Geschenken
die Gewalt das Fremdgehen und das
Betteln um Vergebung werden zu einem
Muster und es ist skaliert immer weiter
irgendwann reicht ein Porsche nicht mehr
einmal kauft oh Jenny Cole einen Ferrari
als Entschuldigung die Diamanten die er
ihr schenkt werden immer größer aber es
ändert sich nichts oJ geht fremd wann
immer es ihm passt und rastet aus wann
immer sie einem anderen Mann seiner
Meinung nach zu viel Aufmerksamkeit
schenkt ja und es ist ja nicht nur die
Eifersucht manchmal treibt es ihm zur
Weißglut wenn das Abendessen nicht genau
dann fertig ist wenn er nach Hause kommt
manchmal rastet er aus wenn das Haus
nicht perfekt in Ordnung ist oder sie in
schlabbrigen bequem Klamotten zu Hause
rumrennt er will sie in jeder Hinsicht
kontrollieren sie gehört ihm und er will
sie nach seinen Vorstellungen man kann
schon sagen dressieren und Formen ja
buchstäblich
so lässt sie sich zum Beispiel
Brustimplantate einsetzen weil er es so
will und es gibt eine Geschichte die ich
besonders schlimm finde obwohl es da
jetzt nicht im körperliche Gewalt geht
als Nicole das zweite Mal schwanger ist
wird er wütend
weil sie zunimmt
ja aber das gehört ja eigentlich
irgendwie dazu oder ja
ich meine das sind halt zwei Menschen
praktisch in einem und dieser Logik kann
sich auch oje nicht ganz ziehen deshalb
gestartet er ihr großzügig wie er ist
dass sie 7 Pfund also amerikanische
Pfund zunimmt darf das sind etwas mehr
als drei Kilo und das ist schon so
absurd wenn man bedenkt dass so ein
normales Geburtsgewicht sogar bis zu
fünf Kilo sein können also wenn man das
alles so hört da kommt einem ständig die
Frage oder ploppt ständig die Frage vor
dem inneren Auge auf wieso hat sie
diesen Typen einfach nicht verlassen die
aber die Antwort ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht einfach oder die Antwort ist nicht
so einfach wie man sich das vorstellt
denn in den meisten Fällen funktioniert
dieses einfach verlassen nämlich
überhaupt gar nicht denn das ganze ist
ja wie eine wahnsinnig komplexe Falle
konstruiert aus Angst Abhängigkeit
Schicksals Ergebenheit und einer Million
individueller Gründe und oft ist trotz
alledem ja auch noch Liebe im Spiel
oder zumindest irgendetwas von dem die
Beteiligten glauben dass das Liebe sein
könnte oh ja bei Nicole kommt das alles
zusammen Angst mehr Angst vor dem was er
tun wird wenn sie ihn verlässt als vor
dem was er ihr regelmäßig schon antut
sie beginnt irgendwann um ihr Leben zu
fürchten sie erzählt sogar Freundinnen
dass er sie umbringen würde wenn sie ihn
verließe und sie ist abhängig von ihm
allein schon finanziell dafür hat er von
Anfang an gesorgt er unterstützt auch
ihre Familie ihrem Vater der nach der
Porsche entschuldigungsgeschichte ihr
erinnert euch schlagartig seine Liebe
zur og entdeckt hat ermöglicht er ein
eigenes Business er bekommt von ihm eine
eigene autoherzvermietungsfiliale und er
bezahlt die Highschool von Nicoles
Schwester ja er ist verdammt großzügig
aber da gibt es eben eine dunkle
Kehrseite die Abhängigkeit
und du hast ja noch einen Grund gesagt
die Schicksals Ergebenheit
viele Opfer von häuslicher Gewalt
akzeptieren irgendwann die Hölle in der
sie leben weil sie glauben dass sie
nichts ändern könnten oder sogar sich
selbst die Schuld geben und dann
arrangieren sie sich irgendwie wieder
mit bauen ihren Alltag darum herum und
da gibt es auch hier so eine kleine
Geschichte die ich besonders
eindrücklich finde
irgendwann im Laufe der Jahre
entschuldigt sich Nicole bei einer
Freundin dass sie sich nicht treffen
konnte weil ihr das Make-up ausgegangen
war und es wird ziemlich klar warum sie
ihre Freundinnen nur geschminkt
gegenübertreten kann ich finde das so
krass diese Vorstellung dass wenn man so
will auf ihrem Einkaufszettel immer
Make-up oder Foundation drauf war
einfach damit sie nicht öfter in so eine
Situation kommt und zum Beispiel nach
blauen Flecken gefragt wird
zwar ihr Alltag was für eine verdrehte
üble Form von Alltag ja und dann ist
dann auch noch die Liebe oder etwas dass
ich wie Liebe anfühlt auch von OJS Seite
er ist überzeugt davon dass er Nicole
liebt und ja all seine Entschuldigungen
und Versprechungen sind wahrscheinlich
in dem Moment in dem man sie ausspricht
komplett ernst gemeint er glaubt sich
selbst wenn er schwört ein besserer
Mensch zu werden ja und sie will ihm
glauben dass ihre eigene Liebe da sind
irgendwann die gemeinsamen Kinder da
sind die großartigen Tage die diese auch
immer wieder gibt und ich habe das
verteilste das immer diese verdammte
Hoffnung bis der nächste
Eifersuchtsanfall ihn zum brutalen
Schläger werden lässt oder er eine
andere Frau sieht die er seine Sammlung
von Affären einverleiben will Nicole
selbst hat man zu einer Freundin gesagt
er liebt mich nicht erst besessen von
mir
ich glaube das ist wirklich die viel
bessere Bezeichnung für deren Beziehung
ja wahrscheinlich trifft es das ganz
genau
viele Jahre später schafft sie es
endlich sich von OJ Simpson zu befreien
doch er kann sie nicht einfach gehen
lassen er kommt nicht von ihr los er
muss zerstören was er nicht besitzen
kann aber dazu kommen wir später jetzt
erstmal zurück ins Jahr 1985 7 Jahre
nach jener ersten Begegnung der
Kellnerin und des Superstars heiraten
die beiden noch im selben Jahr wird ihr
erstes Kind geboren drei Jahre später
das zweite sie leben im Luxus sie sind
beliebt umworben Mittelpunkt jeder Party
aber immer wieder muss Nicole das ganz
ganz dicke Make-up auftragen
und mehrmals wird die Polizei zum
Anwesen der Simpsons gerufen so zum
Beispiel auch im Jahr 1985 im Jahr der
Hochzeit da kommt der Polizeibeamte mag
Firmen der in dieser ganzen Geschichte
noch eine ziemlich große Rolle spielen
wird wegen Verdachts auf häusliche
Gewalt zum Haus der Simpsons er findet
Nicole weinend auf der Motorhaube eines
Mercedes vor die Windschutzscheibe des
Wagens ist zertrümmert Nicole sagt das
oje das getan habe der gibt das zu sagt
aber dass das ein gutes Recht sein der
Wagen sei schließlich sein Eigentum was
er wahrscheinlich nicht dazu gesagt hat
ist dass er auch seine Frau als Eigentum
betrachtet und sich bei ihr das selber
recht herausnimmt
in dem Fall aber hat er seine Wut wohl
ausschließlich an dem Wagen ausgelassen
und Nicole erstattet keine Anzeige
vielleicht noch ein weiteres Beispiel
für eine Situation in der die Polizei
gerufen wurde im Januar 1989 ruft eine
in Panik schreiende Frau den Notruf als
Detective John Edwards und eine Kollegin
eintreffen rennt Nicole auf sie zu sie
hat sich hinter einem Gebüsch versteckt
sie trägt nur Jogginghosen und BH sie
ist offensichtlich schwer misshandelt
worden sie hat blaue Flecken offene
Wunden im Gesicht und würge Male am Hals
und sie schreibt mehrmals er wird mich
töten OJ Simpson fliegt stellt sich aber
später und wird zu zwei Jahren auf
Bewährung verurteilt für einen
einmaligen Fall von häuslicher Gewalt
wahrscheinlich bewahrt ihn Nicole selbst
verschlimmerin indem sie auf weitere
Anzeigen verzichtet
denn klar er hat mal wieder um Vergebung
gebettelt und Besserung gelobt und
natürlich seine Liebe erklärt und das
alles wahrscheinlich besonders
eindrücklich denn seine Werbepartner
haben ihm klargemacht dass alle Deals
platzen wenn er ins Gefängnis muss
1992 kann sich Nicole dann aber endlich
von ihm trennen das Paar wird geschieden
der Terror für damit aber noch lange
nicht auf Simpson will sie noch immer
kontrollieren will sie zurückgewinnen er
bricht in ihre Wohnung ein er
misshandelt sie er terrorisiert sie mit
Telefonanrufen und droht ihr und dann
kurz nach Mitternacht in der Nacht vom
12 zum 13 juli 1994 da finden
Spaziergänger in Brent Los Angeles die
Leichen von Nicole Brown und eines
25-jährigen namens Ronald Goldmann im
Eingangsbereich von Nicoles Anwesen aber
von dieser schrecklichen Nacht erzählen
wir euch in der nächsten Ausgabe und von
allem was danach passierte bis hin zu
einer der seltsamsten und berühmtesten
Verfolgungsjagden aller Zeiten the
Bronco Chase the Bronco Chase unter dem
Namen ist sie in den USA wahrscheinlich
jedem Mal Begriff naja ganz sicher jedem
der damals schon alt genug war um vor
einem Fernseher zu sitzen aber alles im
Detail dann morgen wir hoffen ihr seid
natürlich mit dabei bei der zweiten
Episode unser Mini-Serie über OJ Simpson
bis dann gibt uns gerne Feedback
entweder über Instagram oder per Mail
die Links dazu sind wir immer in den
Shownotes wir freuen uns immer von euch
zu hören bis dann eure Toni und euer
Mirko